[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire avec une semaine de recul
que peut-on dire de ces élections
municipales tout ce que vous avez lu ou
entendu sur la vague verte et sur
l'abstention historique
est ce que c'est vrai et qui a gagné qui
a perdu et est ce que quelque chose a
vraiment changé
mais quoi pour en débattre nous avons
invité non pas les commentateurs
habituels mais le premier c'est antoine
benno qui est écrivain antoine buéno
vous êtes l'auteur entre autres de nos
votes manifeste pour la tension un livre
paru aux éditions autrement
juste avant la dernière élection
présidentielle qu'avez vous retenu de
ces élections antoine mais pour sa part
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est la victoire
de l'abstention mais pas de
l'abstentionnisme et la victoire des
verts mais pas de l'écologie à côté de
vous il y à lucile schmid qui est
cofondatrice de la fabrique écologique
une fondation créée en 2013 dont
l'objectif est de promouvoir l'écologie
et le développement durable sur la base
de propositions pragmatiques et
concrètes vous en est la vice-présidente
en charge des relations universitaires
et de la rubrique décryptage alors vous
les décrypter comment vous ces élections
municipales moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est
que entre le premier et le deuxième tour
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya eu deux
élections totalement différente
dans un cas il ya eu des petites villes
des villages dix villes ou à l'idée des
villes de la ruralité dans l'autre cas
il ya eu la france des métropoles des
grandes villes et des villes moyennes
donc je pense rester comme deux
élections différentes
et puis par rapport à la vague verte ce
qui me frappe aussi c'est que ceux qui
vont être élus maires sont des inconnus
et que on a fait confiance à des
inconnus pour diriger des villes assez
importante
lyon peut-être marseille c'est pas sur
poitiers tours strasbourg donc pourquoi
est-ce que des inconnus sont jugées
légitimes à diriger des grandes villes
je pense que c'est une vraie question
sur l'aspect démocratique
est ce qu'un inconnu au fond n'est pas
aussi capable d'exercer cette
responsabilité que quelqu'un qu'on
connaît depuis 30 ans enfin le troisième
set en pierre henri tavoillot qui est
philosophe
vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur le
siècle des lumières sur la philosophie
politique et sur l'art de gouverner vous
êtes l'auteur entre autres de la guerre
des générations raté lieu avec serge
guérin et de comment gouverner un peuple
le roi un traité nouveaux dark politique
paru l'année dernière chez odile jacob
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé lors de ces
élections c'était très très chiant voilà
c'est l'ennui principal je trouve que
cette campagne n'a pas eu lieu
les consorts du cérémonial républicain
c'est-à-dire la dynamique premier tour
2e tour il ya une dédramatisation et je
pense que c'est une des raisons
essentielles de l'abstention cirque
effectivement en sortie de crise
la déconnexion entre le premier et le
deuxième tour a produit vraiment une
sorte de désintérêt c'étaient les
campagnes doivent avoir lieu elle n'a
pas eu lieu alors d'habitude c'est vrai
que c'est assez facile de commenter les
élections municipales parce que la
majorité au pouvoir
les pères et l'opposition les gagne
c'est comme ça depuis 1977 exactement
c'est toujours comme ça sauf cette fois
ci
et la majorité les a perdus mais on sait
pas qui les a gagné ça alors on parle de
vague verte est ce qu'il ya vraiment eu
une vague verte sur 450 villes de plus
de 20 mille habitants je crois que les
écologistes ont dû en gagner 16 16 sur
450 sachant que y'en a toujours 150 kiki
150 de ces municipalités sur le tour
gouverné par un maire de gauche et je
crois 260 sûr toujours gouvernée par un
maire de droite
alors est ce qu'on peut parler de vague
verte antoine buéno mais ce qui est
important en fait c'est pas tellement
l'aspect numérique des choses mais c'est
lé symbole c'est le fait qu'ils aient
des villes extrêmement importante qu'il
soit tombé dans l'escarcelle de ce qui
apparaît c'est encore comme un
groupuscule politique il ya seulement
quelques années encore plus quelques
décennies qui aurait pu imaginer que des
très grandes villes de france soit
gouvernée par les verts il ya quelques
temps encore c'est ça le véritable
changement dans oui on peut dire que les
verts très très bien sorti leur épingle
du jeu alors il faut dire effectivement
que sur 40 est une ville de cent mille
habitants
il y en a toujours sèche de gauche 15 de
droite et il y en a sept qui sont
gouvernés effectivement aujourd'hui par
des écologistes c'est mieux que que pour
le rassemblement national ou pour les la
république en marche lucile schmid
vous avez l'impression qu'il ya une
vague verte je pense que ce qu'il faut
il faut quand même partir de ce
qu'avaient les verts avant c'est-à-dire
qu'ils avaient grenoble et maintenant il
y en a 16 donc de 1,16 c'est quand même
une dynamique très importante
et la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
par rapport à l'idée du groupuscule là
qui était évoqué c'est qu'effectivement
le parti vert français s'est toujours
caractérisé par son côté coupeurs de
tête c'est un petit parti aussi avec
quelques milliers d'adhérents et là il
conquiert donc de très grandes villes et
donc ça veut dire que je ne sais pas si
c'est le parti vert mais en tout cas
c'est la capacité d'un certain nombre de
verts dans des grandes villes dans les
grandes régions d'avoir su trouver des
candidats qui étaient suffisamment
convaincants pour que ça soit pas juste
du dégagisme parce que s'il y avait que
du dégagisme le plus de rassemblement
national qui aura gagné par exemple donc
il ya un truc très intéressant c'est que
quand je regardais ce que dit le
candidat vert à bordeaux il dit pas la
même chose que le candidat vert a lyon
par exemple
qu'est ce que dit gregory doucet qui a
été élu maire de lyon qu'est ce que dit
bruno bernard qui va diriger la
métropole
eh ben grégory doucet il dit l'écologie
n'est pas l'ennemi de l'économie
vous croyez que le secrétaire national
de élevés d'europe écologie les verts
eelv à dire ça au niveau national dont
jamais donc il ya une vraie capacité
avoir tenu compte de ce qu'on appelle un
microcosme politique culturelle
quand gérard collomb avait gagné lyon en
2001 il avait été capable de convaincre
les lyonnais qu'un maire socialiste
s'était pas dangereux et je crois que
grégory doucet il a fait un petit peu ce
qu'a fait gérard collomb qui avait
failli gérard collomb en 2001 il a
convaincu les lyonnais qui élire un
maire écologiste s'était pas dangereux
ça y est c'est vrai c'était pas gagné et
à bordeaux c'est tout à fait différent
pierre hurmic
c'est un avocat c'est quelqu'un qui a
été l'opposant historique alain juppé
depuis 30 ans 25 ans qui a même fait un
code de la rue alain juppé auquel alain
juppé a même proposé un moment d'être
son adjoint et qui a refusé
donc c'est aussi là cette capacité à
quelque part être à nos pauses en
jaillir à l'anglo saxonne savez comme
une sorte de shadow shadow cabinet tu là
où on fait on est l'opposant qui est
constructif mais qui est opiniâtre et
qui ne se laisse jamais avoir par la
possibilité de devenir un adjoint s'est
pas toujours le cas un moi j'habite les
hauts de seine lors ce qu'andré santini
se s'associer à la république en marche
il ya des gens qui ont été ses opposants
pendant des années qui brusquement vont
travailler qu'andré santini et ça c'est
quelque chose que les électeurs
n'apprécie pas par exemple les
associations d'entre deux tours entre la
république en marche et les républicains
ça n'a jamais fonctionné pendant sept
dans cette élection parce que j'avais le
sentiment que l'alliance de la carpe et
du lapin et est au fond une manière de
défendre des intérêts acquis il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé dans cette
dynamique verte
qui n'est pas seulement dû dégager lis
mon refuge faute d'avoir une offre
politique correct ça a été aussi le fait
de croire dans des personnalités qui
s'adapte et au microcosme qui savait
parler aux électeurs localement et qui
donnait le sentiment d'avoir une forme
d'éthique et d'exemplarité
ensuite c'est mes revers ils vont avoir
une sorte de pression parce que être à
la tête d'un exécutif
franchement c'est nouveau pour les verts
français pierre-henri tavoillot je pense
que ce qui est assez intéressant dans ce
qu'on vit mais depuis quelques années
c'est de voir à quelle allure et quelle
rapidité la question environnementale
est devenue une question prioritaire
avec aussi ce point qui est devenu très
très important c'est que la pensée
écologique devient confrontés à des
options qui sont très différentes et
potentiellement contradictoire c'est un
prophète il ya plusieurs écologie il ya
plusieurs écologie et c'est pour ça que
on est dans une situation où le mot
écologie fait encore vendre si je puis
dire et gagner mais avec une très grande
incertitude sur soul le type d'écologie
qu'étant qui va être mise en place et ça
je trouve que c'est assez révélateur
grosso modo il ya une écologie c'est de
l'écologie qu'on appelle punitive c'est
à dire qui de tendance décroissante east
voir ce qu'on appelle la deep ecology
c'est-à-dire l'écologie qui n'est pas
environnementale mais qui considère que
au fond la nature doit être défendue
pour elle-même la nature de tête et
fronde du porc elle-même est la plus
grande menace à l'égard de la nature
c'est ce sont les humains donc si on
pouvait s'en débarrasser ce serait
formidable
donc ça c'est une première tendance qui
est une tendance un peu un peu radicale
et puis ensuite l'économie
environnementalistes celle qui considère
qu'il doit être possible de faire ce
qu'on appelle le développement durable
c'est à dire qu'au fond si on défend la
nature c'est pas pour la nature mais
c'est pour les humains et la nature est
conçu comme l'environnement inde et des
humains au sein de cette nature
environnementalistes il y a plusieurs
tendances
il ya la tendance effectivement qui
consiste à dire cet environnement
devrait être préservée à tout prix et
donc soyons des 306 soyeux
visons la sobriété modifiant
radicalement toutes nos modes de vie est
comme ça va pas pouvoir se faire
naturellement
il va falloir se soit un tout petit peu
violon un tout petit peu décisif
il y à une autre position si on fait
l'énumération complète la position qui
neutralise c'est à dire zéro déchet il
faut essayer de faire en sorte que au
calme les choses que nos actions que
notre consommation que de transport soit
le moins impactant sur l'environnement
qui est la nôtre et je trouve très
intéressante très stimulante c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'écologie positive
c'est-à-dire l'idée non pas simplement
de décroître non pas simplement d'être
neutre mais de faire en sorte que nos
actions soient favorables à
l'environnement c'est-à-dire faire en
sorte que on a un terrain ben on a une
habitation
non seulement elle est neutre du point
de vue des déchets mais ça produit
quelque chose de positif ça améliore la
nature et donc c'est une troisième
position là aussi très enthousiasmant
dont nous sommes à lure ben de ces
courants qui ne sont pas encore entrés
en conflit avec les ans avec les autres
mais ils vont ils rentrer quel est
l'objectif est ce que c'est le
réchauffement climatique et cela c'est
la biodiversité est ce que c'est la
pollution est ce que celle à
l'épuisement des ressources
tout ça ouvre un débat qui va être
passionnant jeu 3 passionnant par
forcément idéologique on est je crois
encore un peu trop pour le moment
dans une écologie idéologique passons un
peu au pragmatisme
j'aimerais que qu'on regarde une carte
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à trouver une
vraie carte qui nous donne les résultats
de ces les élections municipales et
celles qu'on va voir est l'oeuvre de
pablo raisons qui à 19 ans il est
étudiant en deuxième année à l'école
supérieure de l'image d'angoulême
je les trouvais sur twitter cette cette
carte il a bien voulu nous laisser
l'utiliser pour cette émission et que
nous montre tel ses cartes outre le fait
qu'elle est extrêmement bien décidés et
qu'elle est très précise et c'est
justement ce qui diffère de toutes les
autres soit elles sont trop précises
elle nous montre toutes les communes de
france et on ne voit rien soit elle ne
nous montre que les grandes villes et
notamment celles qui ont été gagnés par
les verts on a l'impression d'une
sur-représentation des verts mais quand
on regarde comme ça on s'aperçoit de
quoi on s'aperçoit qu'il ya pas de va
verte il peut y avoir une percée des
verts et puis avoir une percée
spectaculaire même diront certains quand
on regarde que les grandes villes mais
pour un parti qui est enfin ou du moins
pour des écologistes qui sont entrés sur
le terrain électoral il ya maintenant
pratiquement 50 ans n'en être que là
c'est quand même pas terrible je veux
dire en termes électoraux
bien entendu sachant qu' on est on nous
parle du réchauffement climatique toute
la journée
bada rivé à 1% des municipalités de plus
de 4500 habitants
c'est pas un triomphe si vous regardez
bien ces deux cartes vous verrez
beaucoup de bleu beaucoup de roses très
très peu de vert un peu de benno nom
alors je suis pas du tout d'accord pour
une fois avec votre analyse sur donné
que parce que il faut voir le tableau
dans son ensemble d'abord d'où il
partait ça a été dit par l'autre invité
c'était vraiment pas une image très très
sérieuse au départ et vers la conscience
écologique était totalement anémiée et
donc par delà les résultats électoraux
qui sont quand même réelle surtout
partant de rien du tout il ya aussi
l'imprégnation de l'idée écologique et
tout à l'heure la l'instant vient
d'avoir un panel très exhaustif est
intéressant des différents courants de
l'écologie qui se confrontaient qui vont
peut-être se mélangent et qui vont
accoucher en l'espère de quelque chose
d'intéressant mais les lecteurs quand il
va mettre son bulletin les verts aux
municipales à mon avis le souvent il se
pose pas toutes ces questions et ils
votent pas les verts ils votent
l'écologie
donc la question centrale c'est savoir
où ils en sont justement étant donné que
depuis le début sont complètement
plantés de sur votre bataille
on a des écolos moi je dirais quand aux
pour reprendre l'analogie avec la droite
la plus bête de force
peut-être les ailes et la plus bête du
monde pardon on a peut-être les verts
les plus les plus belles du monde qui en
tenait que me chevaux de bataille depuis
le début les ogm le nucléaire alors que
les priorités absolues en matière
environnementale c'est le réchauffement
climatique et l'effondrement de la
biodiversité
donc on a un paradoxe
qu'on a des dévers dans la bataille et
écologique paraît complètement
l'idéologique vous l'avez dit est une
véritable aspiration maintenant de la
population aussi grâce à ce parti ça
toute la dialectique à changer les
choses d'un point de vue environnemental
rien à ajouter le cheminent cécile bien
sûr des milliers de choses a ajouté ça
va être trop court ouais j'ai bien
compris
non je crois qu'il faut arrêter de
caricaturer en fait les verts c'est à
dire que ce qu'il faut se rappeler
historiquement sans être trop long c'est
que c'est un parti qui s'est d'abord
constitué dans les régions et souvent à
partir d'une lutte contre l'aménagement
du territoire il ya les centrales
nucléaires bien sûr mais dans l'histoire
de ce parti il ya aussi beaucoup les
larzac il ya eu des grands projets
inutiles comme ils disent et par exemple
lorsque strasbourg c'est jeanne
marseillan qui est élu la question du
contournement ouest du grand strasbourg
qui était censé dépolluer la ville il va
sûrement y avoir une modification de ce
projet et c'est quand même très
intéressant de se dire que sur ce sujet
d'aménagement du territoire au moment
d'ailleurs on parle de relocalisation
des activités industrielles
l'élection de mr écologistes dans de
grandes villes va sans doute créer une
discussion un débat sur la question
d'aménagement du territoire
la deuxième chose c'est évidemment la
condition des compromis moi j'écoute est
bien les deux autres invités et moi je
crois que le sujet n'est pas d'expliquer
qu'il ya je sais pas combien de verres
poisson il y avait aussi je suis pas
devin socialiste il ya aussi je sais pas
combien de personnes de droite à dire
que la question des courants dans les
partis politiques n'est pas propre aux
verts vous allez m'expliquer en quoi
valérie pécresse et est compatible avec
je sais par roselyne bachelot
en tout cas il ya quelque chose qui
traverse l'ensemble des partis
politiques se différencier ça fait
partie de la vie partisane
en revanche la façon dont les verts lors
ce qu'ils exerceront dans des
responsabilités seront capables de faire
des compromis est capable de discuter et
d'articuler sur la question sociale et
la question économique par rapport à la
question écologique ça c'est quelque
chose d'essentiel
parce que c'est pas parce que l'écologie
c'est fondamental qu'il faut éviter le
réchauffement climatique et la perte de
biodiversité
il faut oublier la question de la
justice sociale il faut oublier la
question démocratique donc tout l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est comment est ce qu on
articule cette question environnementale
par rapport à ce qu'il fait
les fondements de notre contrat social
et je prends le pari que certains maires
écologistes vont ils réussir et je vous
invite tous à relativiser cette
étiquette
europe ecologie les verts parce que moi
j'ai fait partie d'europe écologie les
verts je ne connaissais aucun aucune des
personnes qui aujourd'hui ont été ou
très peu des personnes qui ont été élus
dans ce parti le national post très peu
par rapport à l'organisation locale et
ça explique sans doute ses succès locaux
que moi je ne relativiserait pas du tout
je pense qu'ils sont fondamentaux et je
pense qu'à partir de là une dynamique va
se construire mais avec des personnes
qui connaissent le microcosme local et
qui ont fait le pari de l'enracinement
local plus sans doute qu'un certain
nombre d'élus des grands partis
politiques français à droite ou à gauche
cette culture locale c'est peut-être
pour ça que les verts ont gagné autant
de villes au deuxième tour des élections
municipales parce que le pari
décentralisateur locale
il existe chez eux de même que le pari
sur l'europe les partis verts dans toute
l'europe
ils font le pari du local et de
l'européen et leur grand problème il est
au niveau national et d'ailleurs ça
montre bien que sans doute la dynamique
locale
elle débouche pas forcément sur un
succès aux présidentielles ou un très
gros score au présentiel
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi ouvrir là
dessus et où oublier le raisonnement
français consistant à dire on est en
train de construire une dynamique pour
les présentiel automatiquement ce qui se
passe au niveau local n'est jamais
transposable chez les écologistes au
niveau national 10 en un mot sur le rat
seul le rassemblement national alors lui
non plus n'a pas gagné il a gagné
perpignan grâce à louis aliot il a il
s'est maintenu dans un certain nombre de
villes qu'ils avaient conquises en 2014
mais le bilan c'est quand même moins
d'élus dans moins de ville qu'en 2014
quelque chose à dire sur le
rassemblement national pierre henri
tavoillot si on regarde la carte vous
aurez beaucoup beaucoup de mal à trouver
des points noirs
plus généralement bon leur semble
nationale ne fait pas le score est ce
compte et c'est pas une élection qui qui
lui est très favorable de façon générale
mais ça exprime quelque chose c'est
pourquoi on ne peut pas parler de vague
verte au fond et pourquoi effectivement
on a eu le test ça va être le sénat on
va bien voir au sénat que effectivement
la droite a gardé sa majorité
ça c'est donc ya pas de vague verte
deuxièmement le clivage que la carte
montre assez bien c'est aussi un clivage
qui existe entre métropole est ce qu'on
appelle la france périphérique donc
d'une certaine façon l'archipel français
jouent sur un domaine
en général quand on est en centre ville
métropole ou réfléchi à la question
environnementale
quand on est un peu éloigné de la
métropole dans la france périphérique
on a tendance à considérer qu'il ya
peut-être des choses encore plus urgente
que ça et de ce point de vue là le
clivage est incontestable donc de ce
point de vue là pas de vague verte à la
fois en valeur absolue mais parce que
aussi la france de ce point de vue là
dans cette préoccupation est largement
clivé largement séparés alors le front
national qui le rassemblement national
qui d'habitude profite davantage de ce
vote protestataire contre les métropoles
las ne profite pas il ya toute une série
d'éléments de contact qui permettent de
l'expliquer les municipales encore une
fois ne sont pas très favorables au
rassemblement national mais je pense que
c'est un élément vraiment centrale pour
comprendre ces élections municipales et
les résultats et qui est un élément
inquiétant c'est un élément inquiétant
parce que là le sentiment effectivement
que des îles et des ce s'éloigne de plus
en plus et que l'abstention que je
verrai pas moi de manière très positive
dans ce domaine parce qu'elle est très
difficile à interpréter
est ce que c'est une abstention de
désintérêt est ce que c'est une
abstention de protestation est ce que
c'est une abstention de colère il ya
toute une série d'éléments qui
permettent assez peu d'identifier ce qui
s'est vraiment passé de ce point de vue
là on parlera l'abstention tout à
l'heure mais antoine penot un mot sur le
rassemblement national qui je le répète
a gardé la plupart des villes qu'ils
avaient conquises en 2014 mais on a
l'impression quand même qu'il n'arrive
pas à s'ancrer territorialement
ce qu'une vieille histoire là encore à
le rassemblement des fidèles maintenant
sur le plan électoral
oui alors c'est un sont des résultats
qui me font plaisir à double titre
d'abord parce que ça fait toujours
plaisir de voir que le rassemblement
national ne rassemble pas et ensuite
quand j'ai sorti mon livre nos votes
manifeste pour l'abstention donc prônant
l'abstention sur tous les plateaux de
télé on a expliqué que l'abstention
favoriser le rassemblement national
là on a une extension absolument record
axone amis et des résultats de
rassemblement national qui sont mauvais
donc en fait c'est pas vrai il n'y a pas
de lien mécanique entre la tension et
l'extrême droite
mais vous n'avez pas d'explication sur
le fait le peu de succès on l'a dit ça
ne favorise pas le rassemblement
national s'était laissé élections
municipales comment l'expliques-tu
pourquoi pourquoi
explications pourquoi est-ce que le
rassemblement national perd
systématiquement les élections
municipales la dent dans ce cas précis
non moi je pense que vous savez sur les
élections municipales il faut aussi être
capable d'avoir une offre correcte c'est
à dire que tout le sujet c'est les
candidats du front national
est-ce qu'ils avaient les bons candidats
la deuxième chose c'est que ça peut
peut-être aussi éclairé ça a été dit
l'abstention c'est un phénomène complexe
donc qui s'est abstenu est ce qu'il est
ce qu a pas eu une abstention de colère
plus forte cette fois ci ou en tout cas
un désintérêt de ce qui si le calendrier
de l'élection avait été normal se
rappelle que d'habitude on votre premier
tour puis une semaine après on vote
deuxième tour donc là il ya quelque
chose qui s'est perdu peut-être de la
colère pourquoi pas où il ya eu une
dépression je pense qu'il ya une forme
de dépression démocratique dans ce qui
se passe mais moi je ne suis pas très
nos votes c'est à dire que je suis
plutôt dans l'idée que tout cas face à
l'abstention
il ne faut pas se résigner il ya quelque
chose a changé dans la proposition que
l'on fait à ce qu'ils élisent donc il ya
quelque chose autour de ça et puis là la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire c'est
que on n'est plus seulement dans l'idée
que l'élection symbolise l'ensemble de
la vie démocratique c'est à dire qu'on
relativise de plus en plus les élections
regardez là
la force des réseaux sociaux va regarder
la force des plateformes où il ya
justement beaucoup de choses qui traite
des questions
moi je suis très anti front national 13
anti rassemblement national donc d
incitation à la haine une grosse forte
présence de l'extrême droite
sk pas là un déversoir kiné qui au fond
est plus important et plus efficace
quand dans le fait d'aller mettre un
bulletin de vote par rapport à la
représentation donc il faut aussi se
poser la question de l'eau est ce que
comment se structurent la vie
démocratique comment est-ce qu'on
relativise de plus en plus la place de
l'élection à la fois lorsqu'on veut
avoir une vie démocratique plus intense
et lorsqu'on fonds se dit bas il vaut
mieux que je proteste sur une plateforme
où il vaut mieux que je regarde
dieudonné ou jeu donc il ya quelque
chose autour de l'idée que peut-être le
parti politique rassemblement national
devrait se poser la question de s qui
représente bien ce qu'il a envie de
représenter et de toute façon la
stratégie de normalisation
j'espère qu'elles échouent antoine penot
quelque chose à ajouter jeu sur ce
rassemblement national qui est capable
de mobiliser 11 millions d'électeurs aux
élections présidentielles et est très
très peu aux élections municipales
est-ce que vous avez une explication
l'explication je crois qu'elle vient
d'être donné c'est vraiment l'équation
personnelle
ce sont des partis qui ont besoin d'un
leader fort derrière lequel le grand
nombre va se fédéraient donc ça
fonctionne à l'échelon national
après sur le territoire il faut trouver
des petits durs qui suscite l'adhésion
qui donne envie et en général les
parties plus anciens qui sont les mieux
implantés qui sont peut-être un peu plus
modérées donne plus envie elle que ce
type d'offre cajori tavoillot oui je
voudrais rajouter quelque chose parce
que d'abord effectivement le
rassemblement national s'appelle
rassemblement national ou qu'il ya
quelque chose qui l'exclût d'une
certaine façon pour principe de du local
même s'il faut être attentif
parmi les théoriciens actuelle du
rassemblement national vous avez juin
qui est inquiétant ce fervent partisan
du localisme et donc il ya une stratégie
de reconquête locale qui est en train de
se mettre en oeuvre qui n'a pas réussi
ce coup ci mais voilà pour la suite il
va falloir être attentif à 7 à cette
évolution
dir
un mot sur l'idée que la taille pour
l'élection très vite une minute
l'idée que l'élection se serait pas le
lieu de la vie démocratique et la
vitalité démocratique faut pas oublier
une chose c'est que l'élection c'est pas
simplement les gens qui votent
l'abstention de gens qui votent c'est
aussi ce qui se présente
neuf cent mille candidats se présentent
en france 600 mille élus c'est à dire un
français sur sont à peu près est élu
donc c'est un truc incroyable c'est le
record du monde en comptant de 10 clubs
démocratie participative que représente
ibéro andalou marche pas c'est juste une
vaste de truanderie on nous avons une
démocratie représentative qui est déjà
extrêmement participative 6 600 mille
élus donc de ce point de vue là
rappelons aussi les choses
l'élection continue d'être la matrice de
la vie démocratique en france on fait
une pause en france débat juste après
[Musique]
qui a gagné les municipales
on continue ce débat avec antoine buéno
avec lucile schmid thé avec pierre henri
tavoillot ans puis henri tavoillot osé
dire quelque chose juste avant la pause
qui ait eu l'air de scandaliser
mais deux autres invités alors la parole
et antoine buéno ben oui vient de nous
dire que il y avait énormément d'élus et
que donc la démocratie représentative
fonctionner moi je les fais juste
remarquer que c'est pas parce que on est
élu quand on participe tous ces élus
vont siéger dans des conseils municipaux
qui n'ont absolument strictement
fondamentalement aucun pouvoir et schmid
mois jusqu'à ce qu'il faut il faut
arrêter d'additionner les choux et les
carottes si je puis dire en tant
qu'écologiste donc on voit bien qu'il ya
d'un côté les grands élus ceux qui ont
beaucoup de pouvoir effectivement à la
tête d'une grande ville comme maire
adjoint quand on participe à l'exécutif
et puis il ya tous ces petits élus de
terrain qui se dévouent bénévolement
dans toutes ces petites communes
françaises
alors moi je ne sais pas d'ailleurs
s'ils n'ont qu'un pouvoir parce que je
pense que le sujet du lien social est un
truc très important notamment en réalité
est que là il ya quelque chose autour du
bénévolat et d'une manière de pratiquer
la représentation qui est
fondamentalement différente de
l'exercice du pouvoir lorsqu'on dirige
une métropole lorsqu'on tirait je parie
lorsqu'on dirige lyon etc
après je pense qu'il ya bout si beaucoup
de gens qui sont élus qui sont déçus de
s'apercevoir et là je rejoins ce que dit
antoine bueno de fait qu' il se pense
élus du peuple et qu'en fait ils
découvrent que le pouvoir il est d'abord
au service à une forme de technocratie
des services qu'en fait il ya une
pratique ultra présentiel entre les
présidents de région et services donc on
est dans une situation où on a sans
doute trop d'élus et il faudrait
s'interroger sur à quoi sert un élu leur
donner du pouvoir et réfléchir à cette
sanction réel qu'ils doivent exercer
il faut aussi des professionnaliser
l'exercice du pouvoir par un certain
nombre de grands élus qui commence à 30
ans
maintenant avant et qui continue jusqu'à
60 ans et j'espère qu'il ya une
réflexion à avoir
pour que de nouveaux on articule aussi
démocratie participer participative et
démocratie représentative
on n'a pas parlé de l'histoire de la
conférence des citoyens pour le climat
mais je pense que la tenue de cette
conférence a montré une dynamique de
personnes peut-être dont certains se
seraient abstenus qui se sont laissé
convaincre de la question écologique et
que d'ailleurs ça a pesé sans doute
aussi dans la dynamique des municipales
il ya une espèce de conjonction des
astres si je puis dire entre le rendu de
la convention citoyenne et là je sais
pas si c'est une vague verte la grande
dynamique verte en ce qui concerne des
villes grandes et moyennes là il ya
quelque chose à regarder sur comment
fonctionne une démocratie et je continue
à penser que la question électorale ne
saurait emporté l'ensemble de la
vitalité démocratique qui enraye oui moi
je suis effectivement un adversaire de
ce concept de démocratie participative
pense qu'il est à la fois flou et quand
il n'est pas fou il est toxique
voilà donc les choses sont dites
pourquoi il est fou parce que c'est des
participations de qui à quoi est-ce que
c'est à la délibération est ce que c'est
à la décision est ce que c'est la
reddition de compte qu'à chaque fois ce
sont des modalités extrêmement
différente des modalités qui peuvent
être toxiques parce que je peux le dire
très clairement j'adore la politique
mais je n'irai pas en faire tous les
jours du matin au soir
et donc si je ne vais pas à une réunion
le soir de démocratie participative qui
liera ma place et bien iront les
militants iront les gens qui ont sont
motivés les gens qui ont le temps et qui
petit à petit prendront le pouvoir et
lui reprend le nom du peuple au nom de
quelques quelques individus à quelques
quelques intérêts donc je trouve que
c'est extrêmement périlleux de lancer
comme ça le mot de démocratie
participative parce qu'il ne veut pas
dire grand chose en vérité et je crois
que c'est extrêmement dangereux de dire
en plus jeune est un argument
supplémentaire c'est que bien souvent
quand on parle de démocratie
participative on veut installer une
autre démocratie représentative ou une
autre représentation avec des gens et
progressivement çà çà çà çà çà çà çà
perdure et c'est donc c'est un concept
extrêmement floues je pense que c'est
très dangereux parce qu'on
fait ça contribue à affaiblir
considérablement la démocratie
représentative sur l'acquis le socle de
nos systèmes contemporain pour des
raisons x de fond et qu'il faut vraiment
préserver comme un trésor parce que si
on affaiblit cette dimension en ajoutant
sans arrêt des instances des logiques et
ses embrouilles totalement le message
est on brouille aussi l'action en
enfermant l'action publique dans une
impuissance accrue je voudrais qu'on
revoilà la carte de pablo raison on va
continuer de faire notre petit tour
je les dis depuis tout à l'heure on voit
bien quand on regarde cette carte qui a
surtout des points bleus et des points
rose
alors qu'en est-il de de la droite et de
la gauche des républicains et du parti
socialiste
ben on a le précieux on voit bien qu'il
se maintienne en fait ils n'ont pas
perdu cette élection
personne ne dit qu'il ils l'ont gagné en
fait ils se sont maintenus dans la
plupart des cas
la gauche progresse même dans dans un
certain nombre de grandes villes
mais la droite se maintient très bien
c'est elle qui avait la majorité toute
façon des municipalités françaises elle
a conservé comme vous le disiez le sénat
ne devrait pas bouger
est-ce quelque chose à dire sur ces deux
formations qu'on avait vu totalement
disparaître aussi bien les républicains
que le parti socialiste à l'issue des
présidentielles des législatives et même
des européennes on avait dit ça y est
c'est fini ça n'existe pas lui ils sont
toujours là quoi
antoine buéno ce que disait le sait une
fuite tout à l'heure était juste
incessant des élections locales donc
l'équation personnelle va avoir un rôle
fondamental
par ailleurs la sarre est encore
schématique de colorier en bleu en rose
parmi tous ces gens quelles étaient les
véritables étiquette est ce qu'ils se
rattacher à des parties de manière
monolithique comment on a l'habitude de
se représenter à l'échelon national
je pense pas quand on regarde les
intitulés des listes de ces des choses
beaucoup plus flou beaucoup plus
rassemblant beaucoup plus local etc
donc on est dans des logiques qui sont
bien différentes de
cette espèce de d'arc en ciel de leur
représentation politique à laquelle on
essaye de se renvoyer parce que ça nous
rassure et ça me permet de commenter lui
chez schmid
oui moi je trouve que ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que quand on a parlé
des écologistes à tout à l'heure
personne n'imaginait qu'il soit ancré à
droite alors que je rappelle qu'il ya
tout un débat sur la question de
l'écologie sur le fait qu'elle puisse
être projet de gauche projet de droite
plutôt qu'elle refoule le projet
politique donc il est clair que lorsque
les écologistes ont gagné ils étaient en
alliance avec la gauche et il est clair
aussi que lorsque des maires sortants de
gauche ont été reconduits comme par
exemple johanna rolland à nantes où
nathalie appéré à rennes
elles ont toutes les deux ce sont deux
femmes elles ont toutes les deux porter
un projet qui était à la fois vert et
rose plutôt rose et vert dans ce cas
précis donc ce qui est intéressant c'est
le fait que les étiquettes classique des
partis politiques aujourd'hui sont en
quelque sorte relativiser par rapport à
des contenus de projet de territoire et
que à partir de là on a olivier faur qui
dirige le parti socialiste mais comment
ce qui saute brusquement du coq à l'âne
et qui nous dit enfonce il y avait un
candidat qui représente le projet social
écologiste on pourrait peut-être
s'effacer bon après il rétro rétropédale
mais on voit bien que en tout cas du
côté de la gauche
comme vous venez de le dire les
positions étaient stabilité il ya même
eu des dynamiques par exemple ps a gagné
la ville de nancy mais ça ne facilite
pas le fait de définir une position
nationale
ensuite ce qui est important par rapport
à ça c'est qu'on se demande et on
revient à l'idée des personnalités si ce
n'est pas à partir des territoires qu'on
pourra refonder je ne sais pas si c'est
des partis politiques moi je crois
qu'ils sont plutôt mort les partis
politiques classiques
même si peut-être pierre henry sera
désolé de cette cette affirmation mais
en tout cas je crois qu'on peut pas
attendre de la démocratie représentative
surtout quand il ya eu 60% d'abstention
à ces élections municipales une vitalité
en revanche on peut attendre de
certaines personnalités d'une offre
politique qui a été plus adaptée à celle
qu'attendaient les électeurs peut-être
quelque chose qui émergent en terme de
renouveau de dynamique mais ce sera en
faisant les liens le lien avec les
citoyens et je termine juste en disant
qu'il faut de plus d'interactivité entre
les citoyens et cette démocratie
représentative vois pas pourquoi on
devrait opposer la démocratie au tour
des citoyens et participative en faire
une espèce de diable par rapport au fait
que aujourd'hui il ya nécessité de
trouver une espèce de résonance de liens
beaucoup plus continue entre ceux qui
nous représentent et qui nous sommes les
citoyens c'est nous aussi et peut-être
qu'il faut effectivement aller dans des
réunions anonyme le soir sous les néons
plutôt qu'à la télévision pour défendre
ce qu'on se comptent ce qu'on a envie de
faire
c'est aussi ça qu'il faut se dire moi
j'ai fait de la politique active et j'ai
adoré les réunions on était trois ours
alpague etc
personne n'en a jamais parlé mais il y
avait de la dans une veine vitalité
humaine qui a pas forcément toujours
dans les assemblées
lui et henri tavoillot dont le test sur
la question de la halle qui a gagné ce
sera effectivement le sénat donc de ce
point de vue là il ya ajouté là dessus
c'est le sénat reste à droite
point de vue là les étiquettes vont se
clarifier sous cette forme
si on relance le débat sur la démocratie
participative encore une fois c'est pas
c'est pas du tout le fait de dire que
notre démocratie représentative
fonctionne formidablement bien ça je
suis évidemment tout à fait d'accord je
pense qu'on se trompe quand on dit que
nous vivons actuellement une crise de la
représentation jeu désolé je pense que
nous n'avons jamais été mieux
représentée aujourd'hui les élus sont
ultra attentif à la manière dont de ce
que pensent les loges leurs citoyens
alors leurs électeurs justement pour
essayer de les gagner pour fragmenter
pour trianguler enfin on a une
représentation qui est extrêmement
précis je pense que c'est en revanche
l'exigence d'un accru de
représentativité qui a augmenté en effet
mais je pense que le noeud du problème
de la démocratie contemporaine c'est pas
tellement le problème de la
représentation c'est plutôt de le
problème de la puissance publique c'est
à dire la décision démocratie vous avez
des masses vous avez kratos des masses
et le pouvoir c'est le peuple et kratos
est le pouvoir et ce cra passe est
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui suscite la
colère des gens c'est on a l'impression
que l'on se heurte dans toute notre
existence à des murailles
d'impossibilité dans toutes nos actions
on sait pas quoi faire on ne sait pas
quoi faire
même sur le réchauffement climatique on
peut pas on peut pas il ya des
règlements et c'est donc je trouve que
vouloir jouer la logique participative
qui va en fait accroître la puissance
publique contre la logique de la
décision me paraît extrêmement
dévastateur et alleo dans le sens de ce
qui favorise actuellement par ailleurs
dans le reste de l'europe et dans
d'autres pays ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie libérale c'est à dire une
démocratie qui dit bon écoute et on va
prendre quelques libertés avec les
libertés et puis ce qui compte au fond
c'est que le peuple soit heureux et que
l'action soit efficace je trouve que
c'est ça qui nous pend au nez c'est pas
du tout un déficit de représentation
alors qui a gagné ces municipales le
vainqueur tout le monde est d'accord
c'est l'abstention
près de 60 % vous l'avez dit
d'abstention un record historique
mais bon en même temps c'est quand même
des élections assez spécial puisqu'il
s'est passé quinze semaines entre les
deux tours et une pandémie qui incitait
plutôt à rester chez soi surtout quand
on était un électorat j'ai alors vous
qui êtes à un grand promoteur de
l'abstention antoine buéno est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que fut une
victoire de l'abstention ou c'est une
victoire du gros navires us
alors évidemment c'est une victoire de
l'abstention mais pas de
l'abstentionnisme jeu c'est un vrai
distinguo entre les deux
l'absentionnisme c est ce que j'ai
défendue est mort c'est à dire l'idée
que vous pouvez s'abstenir pour des
raisons politiques et que le fait de
s'abstenir
pouvait transmettre un message politique
voire être réformateur en l'occurrence
je me rends bien compte que c'est pas le
cas il ya une vraie opposition entre
souvent la sécurité et la liberté
aujourd'hui avec le confinement
l'urgence sanitaire on est dans une
optique général le sécuritaire et dans
ces cas là on a beaucoup moins envie
d'avoir de liberté on préfère être
dirigée être mené là où il faut avoir
des directives et je crois que cette
ambiance générale pâtit à l'élection
constitue dans une optique de
participations ou d'abstention parce que
encore une fois dans mon optique
s'abstenir c'est aussi une manière de
participer les jeunes schmid
oui moi je trouve que ce que dit antoine
buéno sur l'abstention c'est intéressant
mais moi j'aurais plutôt vu du côté du
vote blanc parce que je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose d'assez fort à se déplacer
à voter blanc bon après c'est peut-être
parce que je m'intéresse tellement la
politique ça m'est déjà arrivé de voter
blanc dans ma vie mais où mais rarement
de très rarement de m'abstenir
non je pense que ce qui est aussi assez
assez passionnant c'est en revenant sur
cette question de l'offre politique et
de qui se présente aux élections
si je reviens sur les verts
c'est une sociologie complètement
différente du pouvoir puisqu'on
démocrates aux démocrates au sénat vous
avez grégory doucet à lyon qui est un
ancien cadre de handicap international
et qui a fait de l'humanitaire à
l'étranger pendant très longtemps
vous avez les aux normes ont conduit à
poitiers qui a 30 ans avec qui ce
qu'elle explique grosso modo c'est que
bon elle a fait pas mal d'études et l
art parle de son expérience quand elle
était scout unionistes donc chez les
protestants et raconte sa relation à la
nature par rapport à ça moi je trouve ça
assez assez drôle d'une certaine manière
c'est à dire qu'on a les personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui en responsabilité qu'on
n'aurait jamais imaginé être
effectivement non représentants il ya
encore quelques semaines quelques mois
ci d'ailleurs ce calendrier des
élections municipales n'avaient pas été
complètement dérangé donc peut-être
qu'effectivement la représentation va
retrouver des couleurs
parce que des personnes on n'aurait
jamais imaginé au pouvoir vont s'y
retrouver
c'est un pari à prendre mais je ne crois
pas qu'il faille déconnecté ce pari de
forme d'autres types de démocratie
d'ailleurs les aux normes ont conduit
donc à la 30 ans elle dit moi je vais
rendre poitiers plus démocratique
il faudra savoir ce qu'elle appelle plus
démocratique c'est à dire que est-ce que
c'est uniquement faire effectivement la
concertation ou est ce que ça veut dire
associé à la décision et faire des
compromis avec des personnes qui ne
seront pas des écologistes
ça c'est un point essentiel je lisais
que sébastian roché qui est spécialisé
questions de sécurité avait écrit un
article en disant maintenant qu'il ya
des verts des écologistes qui vont être
au pouvoir dans les grandes villes la
conception de la sécurité va aussi
fondamentalement évolué je trouve ça
intéressant dire qu'on est face à
quelque chose d'assez radicalement
nouveau parce qu'à une sociologie du
pouvoir et des personnes qui porte un
projet différent qui vont peut-être
revisité certes les questions
environnementales ça on s'y attend mais
aussi d'autres manières de faire sur les
questions sociales sur les questions de
sécurité sur l'investissement des villes
sur l'aménagement du territoire
donc ce qui a gagné ces municipales
c'est peut-être une manière de
complètement reconsidéré et bouleversé
la logique du projet de ville et la
logique du projet territorial
sébastien roché qui est souvent revenu
dans cette émission
pierre henri tavoillot je rappelle 1.2
historique athènes dont
la grande phase de la démocratie antique
le vote blanc est interdit dans le
meilleur des cas si vous votez blanc
vous êtes ostracisés dans le pire des
cas vous êtes exécuté l'idée forte c'est
à dire l'idée effectivement que le vote
est participatif c'est le vote c'est la
tâche par excellence du citoyen et le
citoyen se définit comme participation à
travers d'aidés certain nombre de
magistrature donc voté blanc c'est se
mettre en dehors de la cité
ah c'est ça la logique évidemment nous
sommes dans démocratie libérale dans des
démocraties libérales
on ne va pas forcer en général de voter
ou ne pas voter on a le droit de
s'abstenir mais voyez l'esprit de la
démocratie c'est pas du tout de dire
voilà je n'ai pas je suis contraint de
prendre parti et j'ajoute un point c'est
l'idée très profonde que le lecteur
n'est pas seulement celui qui vote c'est
à dire je vote mais intérêt mais
l'électeur est lui-même un représentant
les lecteurs est lui-même un
représentant s'ils représentent tous
ceux qui ne peuvent pas voter dont il
doit prendre en charge les intéresse et
si on pense que l'électeur vote
uniquement pour ses intérêts c'est même
pas la peine d'installer la démocratie
aura mis une bonne vieille dictature ça
sera beaucoup plus et film efficace
parce que l'anthropologie qui a des
recettes cette idée qu'on vote pour ses
intérêts c'est juste une anthropologique
est détestable
les électeurs votent pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas voter c'est enfance etc les
générations futures
éventuellement l'environnement
éventuellement les animaux que ça je
m'en fais ils votent pour plus que lui
et cette idée là est très importante ça
veut dire que l'électeur est responsable
c'est pour ça que faire l'apologie de
l'abstention je trouvais très contraire
à l'esprit des démocraties
représentatives parce que c'est
précisément oublier cet immense
responsabilité de la citoyenneté
alors on peut s'amuser c'est un peu un
sophiste en disant voilà protester
contre le système on n'aime pas le
système qu'est ce que ça veut dire au
fond ça veut dire qu'on veut que les
politiques pour lequel on vote pas fait
il soit ça soit nous on considère que
l'offre électorale est passée à est
passé en pl l'a jamais été aussi
qu'aujourd'hui
donc franchement si on veut dire l'offre
électorale qui me mets présentés que ce
soit présidentielle ou aux municipales
ne correspond pas à mes désirs
il n'y a qu'une chose à faire c'est se
présenter soit même alors antoine penot
va rectifier ça
boutin vous écoutent oui alors il nous
faudrait une émission entière fédérer
comment je voulais déjà donné à l'époque
des biches entière sur l'abstention
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais en fait tout
ce qui vient d'être dit mme meurisse le
poil d'ailleurs je remercie pierre henry
parce que vraiment là il y avait à voir
la totalité alors fait juste dire une
petite chose c'est que le terme de
démocratie que vous employez à tout bout
de champ et totalement galvaudé il y à
une contradiction absolue dans les
termes et fondamentalement entre ce
qu'est la démocratie vous avez cité
athènes et ce qu'est le système de la
représentation
le système de la représentation n'est
pas du tout la démocratie c'est un
système de l'oligarchie élective
alors moi je connais bien le système de
la représentation parce que j'y
travaille je sais pas si pierre henry a
essayé de se présenter à des élections
et ben non pierre henry tout le monde ne
peut pas le faire et puis même si vous
pouvez vous présenter tout le monde ne
peut pas gagner c'est très compliqué et
pourquoi c'est très compliqué parce
qu'il faut maîtriser un certain nombre
de codes un certain nombre de réseaux
avoir un certain nombre de moyens tout
ça est en forme at et non pas pas
l'offre politique mais par le système et
ce système vous pouvez en faire quelque
chose de très différent alors je parle
pas de démocratie participative
forcément mais quelque chose qui
permette véritablement au moins ça
serait déjà un progrès aux 600 mille
élus que vous citez d'avoir un
quelconque droit de regard sur les
décisions qui sont prises
cette émission là elle est consacrée aux
municipales et des rues municipales le
sismique la digue à 3 4 personnes 5 6
qui sont à la tête des villes qui
prennent des décisions et tous les
autres tous les élus sont là derrière
pour faire la claque
ap le tenir pour entériner des décisions
ça s'appelle un vernis et à dimanche
foutage de gueule dans ces conditions
s'abstenir c'est au minimum exprimé que
on a les yeux ouverts et qu'on voit bien
tout ça on arrête là le débat sur
l'abstention à moins qu aurait bien au
réveil est absolument elle ajouté gain
du jeu mais très court
recommandez mon livre parce que
manifestement l'esprit de la démocratie
représentative n'est pas compris et j'ai
passé sept ans à écrire ce livre a fait
recours auprès des étudiants justement
pour redire pourquoi les élections sont
devenus démocratiques pourquoi le
système qui en effet oligarchique et
devenus démocratiques dans la pratique
et là vraiment je trouve que pardon
l'analyse que vous faites aux lèvres de
l'étudiant de première année qui arrive
en philosophie politique à l'université
john cabot coup de chants paillards bon
et il nous reste quelques minutes je
voudrais poser la question des oui
antoine penot et moi je moi je partis
oui et leur donner l et j -l hier henry
est en règle je suis peut-être un petit
étudiant de première année mais ses
conclusions la sont aussi le fruit de
dix sept années de travail au parlement
venez faire un stage comme ça l'étude en
première année pourra avoir un stage et
est élu c'est lui alors si vous voulez
ajouter votre grain de sel je voulais
vous poser une dernière question c'est
le fait qu'il y a quand même cinq des
dix plus grandes villes de france qui
sont désormais
gouvernée par des femmes et
il ya eu une percée des femmes lors de
ces élections municipales est-ce que
vous avez l'impression parce que pour
moi c'est ça la grande question s'il ya
des écolos à la tête des municipalités
on peut imaginer qu'ils vont gouverner
différemment des autres formations
politiques
est ce que quand une femme arrive aux
affaires à la tête d'une municipalité
d'une grande municipalité ou d'une
municipalité de taille moyenne
est-ce que c'est différent à votre avis
je crois pas du tout que ce soit
différent sur la psychologie c'est à
dire que je pense que l'idée que les
femmes sont plus collective tout ça ah
bon ça je suis pas sûr que j'y crois
quand elles font de la politique
en revanche je pense que sur la question
écologique il ya une vraie différence
sur la façon dont les femmes enfin un
certain nombre de femmes que j'ai
croisés et aujourd'hui dans les femmes
qui sont mères elles ont eu l'intuition
que ça allait devenir une grande
question politique
d'ailleurs j'avais dit en riant que
ségolène royal qui a beaucoup de défauts
a eu aussi cette intuition beaucoup plus
tôt que la plupart des hommes
donc je fais le pari qu'en tout cas ces
femmes à la tête des grandes villes
françaises
elles donneront à l'écologie beaucoup
d'importance et qu'elles seront
l'articuler avec leur capacité de
décision
je suis pas sûr que je pense que par
exemple certains hommes qui ont perdu à
cette élection n'avait pas ne s'était
pas dit à quel point les électeurs
penser que la question écologique
environnemental comme certains disent
était au centre du jeu maintenant donc
je pense que sur ce sujet les femmes
sont avant gardiste et sans vouloir
faire de l'essentialisme parce que je
sais que plein de fameux dirais mais
qu'est ce que tu racontes regarder ce
qui se relève l'écoféminisme et regarder
comment hal hidalgo qui est socialiste a
su sur l'écologie quelque part absorber
une grande partie du programme des verts
parisiens pour au fond de faire le score
qu'a l'a fait je crois qu'elle a
vraiment fonder structurer sa victoire
sur la question écologique
alors l'état voillot sur les femmes qui
arrive est la tête de de nombreuses
municipalités
bah je trouve que à partir du moment où
on le remarque mais même plus et que ça
arrive en fin d'émission j'allais dire
la nouvelle est arrivée et c'est une
excellente chose c'est même plus un
point de commentaires si je puis dire
non je reviendrai juste sur l'éco
féministe parce que ça ça me paraît un
peu plus périlleux c'est l'écoféminisme
au fond c'est une idéologie qui
considère que parce que les femmes
enfants elles sont plus proches de
l'aneth
parce que ça non je pense que c'est ça
la nature et non mais moi vous savez
j'ai fait dix ans d'écologie politique
vous avez fait 17 ans ne sais pas quoi
non là je crois que vous pourrez
capturer l'écoféminisme mais je pense
qu'on peut avoir une femme enfant et
qu'elles sont féministes et et inique
elles sont écologistes non pardon mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'idéologie échos féministe dans ce cas
là le plus radical on peut être
écologiste et féministe il ya aucun
problème c'est mais l'écoféminisme comme
idéologie c'est une idée que je trouve
extrêmement chercheuse et des chasses
parce qu elle c'est une sorte de
machisme à verser c'est à dire qu'on
considère que les femmes sont
formidables parce qu'en tout plus proche
de la nature et que les hommes sont
productifs c'est pas du tout ça
non c'est ça n'est pas du tout ça on
peut jeter toute une série d'hommes et
auteurs américains et simplement
attention il est tout à fait post et
féministe derniers mots antoine buéno
non non non le professeur l'écoféminisme
c'est juste prendre conscience que
l'amélioration de notre rapport à la
nature passe aussi par l'amélioration de
la condition des femmes
bon lucile schmid un dernier mot moi je
pense que je suis désolé d'avoir d'abord
lancé une autre petite polémique mais au
fond pourquoi pas le dernier mot c'est
moi je crois qu'on remarque quand même
que les fans deviennent mères parce que
c'était le seul point dans le champ
politique sur lequel il y avait encore
beaucoup moins de femmes que d'hommes
donc je pense que c'est assez historique
ce qui s'est passé et que jusqu'à
présent vous savez les femmes et était
toujours première adjointe et là en fait
elles vont avoir un premier adjoint qui
sera un homme et je pense que ça sera
pas plus mal fait et mais encore une
fois regardons les choses sur le contenu
de ce qu'elles feront et ne disons pas
tout de suite c'est merveilleux parce
que ce sont des femmes les femmes
elle souhaite aussi être jugés sur leurs
actes dernier mot puis à 8 à boyaux pas
le dernier mot je pense était encore
l'une où il vous reste 20 secondes on
peut espérer que
cette vague verte conduisent à une
véritable écologie smeap règne enfin
d'écologisme les politiques menées en
particulier au niveau national par
d'autres que les écologistes que les
verts merci tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]